um
um this thing is gonna burst out of
somebody's chest i can just see it this
is this thing is this thing is
horrifying they look comfy
i feel like it's breathable kind of
reminds me of a boy on tinder who's
showing a picture of him fishing i mean
this in the kindest way possible to me
i'd rather not wear gloves and wear
those gloves i think this skin is is
cool that's sick i like that i like the
spinny thing in the middle that's a dub
in my books what i like about this
though is i like you i can tell that
you've worn them a lot yeah i mean this
is like also in the kindest way possible
you look like a clown
i can't get behind this i can't get
behind reaver i never will be able to
it's hideous i do like the color
coordination on the buddy you could
achieve probably even better color
coordination with a riot gun buddy is
that a dragon dragons are cool i like
dragons is that samuya i see smelia hot
take i think it's really cool like it's
kind of striking at first but then like
once you like really look at it i'm like
i actually really like that art style i
like it 10 out of 10 for me